culpable Ese fue el veredicto del Jurado
contra la organización Trump el crimen
un plan de 15 años para defraudar a las
autoridades Fiscales tras diez horas de
deliberaciones y tres años de
investigación dos entidades de la
organización Fueron imputadas por 17
cargos entre ellos conspiración y
falsificación de registros comerciales
Ese fue un caso sobre mentiras y engaños
con documentos falsos para que
individuos y corporaciones pudieran
evadir impuestos
en el entramado la organización Trump
habría ayudado a altos ejecutivos a
evadir los impuestos de bienes de lujo
como autos de alta gama o apartamentos
en Manhattan por lo que la asociación
enfrenta una multa de hasta 1,6 millones
de dólares una decisión que los acusados
planean apelar
sin duda pelaremos por supuesto vamos a
centrarnos en la definición del concepto
en nombre de hemos presentado una gran
cantidad de documentos sobre lo que con
esas palabras
un escándalo que aunque no incumbe al
expresidente Donald Trump directamente
Se presenta como una nueva complicación
en su carrera por conseguir la
presidencia en 2024
hace muchos años un famoso político de
la zona de Boston Joseph Michael curly
ganó la reelección a la cámara de
representantes desde una celda la única
cuestión es si los estadounidenses
votarían o no Para que eso ocurriera
[Música]
ahora el siguiente paso es la sentencia
sobre el caso que se espera llegue el 13
de enero otra fecha señalada para el
expresidente Trump